último fin de semana electoral en Chile
las campañas tanto de la prueba como del
rechazo últimas sus estrategias y salen
a las calles decididas a conquistar
aquel grupo de indecisos que todavía no
sabes si votar apruebo a la nueva
propuesta constitucional presentada por
154 convencionales constitucionales el
pasado 4 de julio o rechazo manteniendo
así vigente en la actual Constitución
que Data de 1980 y fue heredada de la
dictadura de Augusto pinochet la máxima
incógnita de esta elección es que por
primera vez desde 2012 el voto será
obligatorio Y eso podría movilizar una
masa de lectores cuyo comportamiento es
desconocido las encuestas publicadas
como marca la ley electoral como mínimo
15 días antes del plebiscito para no
influenciar los resultados dan como
favorito al rechazo Aunque la brecha
entre ambas opciones se había ido
reduciendo en las últimas semanas el
clima que se vive en Chile es de máxima
incertidumbre eso que es un país
acostumbrado en los últimos años a vivir
procesos electorales importantes nadie
sabe muy bien Qué es lo que va a pasar
algo que transmite el propio gobierno
favorable a la prueba pero que ha
desplegado encima de la mesa en caso de
que gane la prueba pero también en caso
de que gane el rechazo como decía el
propio presidente Gabriel borich la
semana pasada si esto fuera el caso
habría que iniciar un nuevo proceso para
elegir a convencionales constitucionales
elaborar un nuevo texto constitucional Y
de nuevo realizar un nuevo plebiscito de
salida